pas faire une interview oui non ça sera
facile vous avez la pente par oui ou par
non
je vous fais
et il
dix heures tu pourras la peine ce trio
ya bien du think that is it girl sexy
demain iseli d'un hold up with it had to
see you love story jason gann avanade
le pdg de news people
[Musique]
ils sont amis de rising ou non 9
constat d'un défaut comme vous êtes
étrangères il fait du mal vous parlait
bien français mais c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour vous belinda ras-le-bol
donc on va faire une interview oui non
merci
avec
[Applaudissements]
mais je peux pas quand vous commencez à
musique géante en éruption et bien
franchement bon alors interné oui non
vous devez répondre oui ou non
yes or no bien son nom robin lehner par
des chiens vent thierry si vous trompiez
votre mec est ce que vous lui diriez à
c'est très difficile elle a fait déjà y
en a
pourquoi non mais j'ai pas loin parce
que je suis pas du tout une bonne
menteuse je sais pas faire y at il
encore un fantasme que vous n'ayez pas
réalisé qu'un comique
oui tu vois les noms n'ont étrangement
pas est-ce que vous tour ne riez dans un
film porno pour un million de dollars 2
millions de dollars 3 millions de
dollars est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences homosexuelles
[Musique]
charmeuse à une petite année mézague
[Applaudissements]
absolument je crois qu'on en est sûre ce
soir
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences à plusieurs est-ce qu'on
peut aimer plusieurs fois dans sa vie
yes est-ce que vous accepteriez de vous
réincarner en jennifer lopez a est ce
que vous vous aimez est-ce que vous mais
m je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
[Musique]
et enfin
est ce que tu penses tu réponds que par
oui ou par non est ce que tu penses
est ce que tu penses que tu mérites qui
est arrivé non d'accord est ce que tu
penses que ça va durer
plantant oui
est ce que si le scénariste était
vraiment intelligente du frein porno
somme
[Musique]
est-ce que tu éteins la lumière avant de
finalement à bon tu l'as lu monsieur
l'étape
oui est-ce qu'il était arrivé de faire
l'amour hier que dans un lit
twilight impatience
oui est-ce que c'était arrivé d'avoir le
coup de foudre pour que ça passe et que
ça devienne sexuelles dans les cinq
minutes qui suivent je me renseigne ses
portes en question
ces personnels torréon de cet été
surprise par thomas calinon t'imagines
faire ça sur service-public spontanéité
point
non toi tu as honte
ça me libérer
c'est déjà arrivé la même
bon dernière question est-ce que tu
thème oui non
alors tu fais de l'art ni oui ni non
lorsqu'au moment tu tu aime ou pas
[Musique]
c
qu'est ce que tu penses que ça va durer
comme ça que tu vas continuer à faire
des grands films et être une cithare
peux tu dire l'angleterre qui passent
beaucoup de temps libre
enfin bon est ce que tu penses que ça va
continuer oui est ce que tu penses qu'il
faut coucher pour réussir à coucher
coucher avec un homme couché pour non
vraiment pas ah bon non est-ce que tu
qui traite ou pour un grand amour sur
demain matin tu joues dans un film et
bien l'acteur qui est en face de toi si
vraiment tu dis c'est le quatrième homme
de ma vie parce que tu quitteras non je
ne quitterai pas d'avis les ont tués qui
trompe pas non je peux pas aller chez
les enfants que j'adore chez les enfants
oui mais c'est aussi mon mari mes jeux g
on peut tomber en amour mais c'est pas
nécessaire d
arrêter les abus dans sa petite aventure
mais cette fois ci pas fait mais je suis
pas agi par contre et nous mourons de
requins avant non depuis sept ans qui
avec thomas oui jamais rencontré
mais je dois bien zen et il est bien
il a bien et les médias toujours su me
plaît
qui sera en hauteur est ce que tu dis
des expériences de instanz ex tu vois un
type comme ça qu'ils ont envie de faire
l'amour avec lui dans les 30 secondes
ah oui passé ah oui ça devait arriver
oui bon avoir un papa puisse être avant
bien sûr c'est un jeu est-ce que ça mais
ce n'était pas un jeu de 35 ans mais ça
c'est dit 30 minutes trois minutes
pendant 3 minutes 30 minutes
est-ce que c'est très personnel
est ce que c'est la langue c'est super
c'est une émission qui passe très très
tard j'espère est ce que pour faire
l'amour est ce que tu arrives de laisser
la lumière allumée ou tu étais un
systématiquement la lumière non
j'insiste je mets
si cette année mais tu leur salut mais
si elle change pas je suis très lisible
supporters et j'ai très très pas
seulement ça
vous faites
kieffer
[Musique]
est-ce que tu qui traite tous pour un
grand m
sa carrière sont formidables comme ça
harris aimé en faire une seule fois 106
non voilà c'est franchement tu veux plus
la cei
est ce que tu crois qu'il faut coucher
pour réussir c'est
c'est ce que je fais là l'opposé de ce
que je dis enfin c'est ce que je combats
sachet de question donc c'est non oui
non non il a dit qu'une fois il va
réalisateur qu'il allait convoquer dans
ton takara ni m'enseigner pas dire le
nom n'en serait pas arrivé tard non mais
je vois pas ce que j'aime pas
déshabiller probablement j'étais fait et
moi j'aime pas ça elle ne trouve pas de
fête
je sais pas ça c'est pas le problème est
supportable il m'a dit que pour être
actrice il faut se montrer pour alcoa et
moi samassa m'insupporter jeu j'avais
présent et ça a été l'horreur et ça m'a
donné encore plus envie de faire ce
métier mais n'est pas dans ce sens là
je vais envoyer un truc à ckoi scénario
ou quelque chose comme ça où un cendrier
je ne sais plus comment il a réagi
j'ai pas eu le temps de voir je suis
parti tout de suite ça plus jamais eu de
nouvelles de lui
non ce qui m'a dit un jour qu'il
trouvait très bien dans un film et
j'étais assez culotté assez désagrégea
prix qui est en place quand je vais pas
le dire est ce qu'on va savoir qui c'est
est-ce que tutelle
tiens
tes choix veut pas dire oui ou non à ce
moment là je dirai non
tout fatale et j'ai pas de singer un
gros plus [ __ ] me rappelle moi je dis
ça mais je n'ai pas inventé avant
non je n'aime pas tellement mais
mais je m'accepte quand même j'essaye de
voir
j'essaie déjà de m'accepter intérieur
puis bon physique ça vient premi
déjà nous a glissé
ce que je suis déjà intérieur
déjà ça c'est ta faute parce que tu
crois en dieu oui tu me fous
kiffer
[Musique]
est ce que tu penses qu'il faut coucher
pour réussir non tout ça les journées de
13 ans chez les minimes qui me désole
est-ce que tu serais prête à coucher
pour un scoop et nord est vraiment bon
sens pas être donné ta vie mais la
couche et on secoue pour l'agencé alors
vite fait castro le mec tu dis les la
castro veut d'abord señorita j'ai pas le
droit de dire je ne sais pas monsieur
jamais dit oui pourquoi j'apprécie tout
sera augmentée c'est bien comme cela
j'en ai encore une nation est ce que tu
écris tu ferais tout pour levante ah ben
oui parce que tu as un grand tabou
l'instrument oui
alors est-ce que tu éteins la lumière
n'ont pas toujours entre parenthèses
d'accord est ce que tu es déjà fait
l'amour dans un ascenseur oui à bâle
est-ce que tu es déjà connu line
systèmes cette rencontre avec l' essai
dix secondes dans les dix bombes et 15
secondes supporters des minutes deux
minutes quand même son bien est ce que
tu crois en dieu
[Musique]
oui tu pries des fois quand tu allais
balanche et je passe dédiés
j'arrête de fumer je suis par jour
régulièrement mais je passe beaucoup de
buts je discute apparemment oui
au fait
et j'ai faim
[Musique]
oh
est ce que tu penses que ça va durer au
fond à la télé non par la télé comme ça
on est dans les cris oui voilà tu es
l'étais pas je vois comment les gens
sont rejetés
p mais qui sur la plus de 20 ans ouais
mais on n'est pas la même époque
ça va plus vite ça va beaucoup plus vite
donc là tu réponds oui mais non je
réponds d'en turet pour les missions à
venir
est ce que si tu aimes le mec avec qui
tu étais prêt à tout faire
dans paris turf personne va draguer
parce que tu as déjà fait l'amour sur
l'ascenseur bon est ce que tu dis que tu
vois qu'un écran de nuit avec tout le
monde dit qu'ils ont de moi non plus
mais bon on aurait eu les jambes et
parents des trucs là c'est tout le monde
le dit de l'accord non c'est non
est-ce que tu déjà eu une expérience
soit honnête tout est toute petite à la
colo une expérience homosexuelle
non
calais ou encore mais est-ce que alors
est-ce que tu couches avec christophe
dechavanne dit on sans lui le 3 millions
pour 100 milliards de milliards de
milliards
bon avec frédéric mitterrand dix mille
sont ni la rio a milliard d'euros c'est
pas des fichiers
n'empêche qu'à fait encore bernard a
fait chauffer à la logique avec bernard
à 10% francs pour 100 francs rien c'est
le seul pour rire chansons
combien assez tendue cet ordre est ce
que tu aimes
oui un peu oui oui oui oui bah oui oui
est ce que tu crois en dieu non je crois
pas non c'est pas dur de vivre sans quoi
on dit aussi s'était notamment dit oui
j'aimerais bien tu as préféré la
psychanalyse mais là j'ai écouté n'ont
pas la foi non je souffre ouais mais je
sais pas tu sais je suis d'une famille
s'est enfoncé les crucifix sur fond de
la gorge donc c'était un peu dur de
renvoyer après de guéret pour toujours
dit qu'en fait j'ai entendu beaucoup de
choses quand j'étais pas ce genre de se
voir ça je crois tu feras pas une prière
le 24 au soir
non c'est la non mais je prendrais bien
plutôt faire une prière prendre des
trucs des machins des médicaments je
préfère ça ouais ça marchera mieux ouais
évidemment ça marchera mieux
kiffer
[Musique]
c'est à la lumière pour faire l'amour
non est ce que tu aimes faire l'amour
ailleurs que dans un livre oui car
beaucoup de l'endroit le plus fou tu
étais la manche c'est quoi
à part un palais en iran je reconnais
que c'est assez recherchée mais à part
ça les gens ne paient ni ses pas dans la
piscine nafissa à l'ascenseur tout le
monde dit la serbe soit c'est vrai ouais
arrêté l'ascenseur ou encore à ben
arrêter ça reste bloquée si tu te
trompes et on je lui dirais tu crois que
je dirais pas du tout pourquoi je ne
dirais pas parce que je trouve quand on
fait des conneries
bon ou en trophées en ce cas ce
qu'aurait on fait des corps mais il faut
assumer le fait de l'expliquer c'est
déjà pour se faire pardonner ce sont des
gages ouais parce que tu crois en dieu
je prends est-ce que tu thème quand
j'écris quand j'écris ce mois ci non
enfin je m'aime vraiment quand j'ai créé
sinon quand je reviens des caraïbes quoi
se vanter
ouais c'est pas mal non est-ce que
derrière question tu regrettes tu es
devenu dans cette émission
qui fait l'homme
est-ce que vous pensez que vous méritez
ce qui vous arrive oui oui oui oui bien
sûr oui moi je crois qu'on a le destin
qu'on mérite c'est un peu bon c'est un
peu dur de dire ça alors que bon la
misère est immense bon d'accord mais je
crois que si on rêve sa vie on obtient à
peu près ce que vous savez les [ __ ]
sont des [ __ ] et on rêvait d'être
salon je le crois oui parce que vous
pensez que ça va durer je l'espère oui
oui vous savez je suis allé voir un
astrologue
j'ai adoré l'idée d'aller voir un
astrologue et m'a dit au bout serait une
vieille dame très heureuse
alors là ça m'a enchanté maintenant
vraiment je suis beaucoup plus cool
depuis que je sais ça pour le mariage
iberia
non non dommage qu est-ce que vous pas
qu'il faut coucher pour réussir
non est ce que vous croyez qu'il faut
éteindre la lumière pour faire l'amour
non donc est ce que vous pensez qu'on
doit faire l'amour ailleurs que dans un
livre
ah oui mais des endroits est ce que si
vous trompiez votre fiancée nous pas
savoir si vous lui diriez ou pas c'est
pas important que vous ne trouveriez pas
il a beaucoup de chance écoutez c'est en
même temps très voluptueuse à tromper
quelqu'un
délicieux on cristallise on focalise
complètement sur cette personne c'est un
temps c'est tellement
complexe tellement mystérieux est ce que
tout un jeu si vous aimez galles gars
vraiment très très fort vous êtes prête
à tout faire avec lui oui est ce que
vous auriez rond d'être surprise par de
financer avec une fille dans un lit soir
quand ils rentrent et vous trouve dans
le lit avec une fille vous aurions donc
non pas le mot je serai je me serais
mise dans une position très extravagante
c'est considéré comme tromper ou pas les
filles écoutez tout de même et peut-être
moins un moment parce que vous avez déjà
eu des expériences diensten sexe oui
mais toujours avec le même
vous croyez en dieu
oui bien ce côté des pyramides bleues je
resterai 14e une jeunesse très
catholique et je suis très heureuse de
la voir parce que vous savez quand je
suis entré tout petit pour la première
fois dans une église et que j'ai vu le
christ crucifié
alors je pleurais
mais ça
enfin y'a pas de mots ça m'a bouleversé
profondément et jeunes cette figure du
christ qui se sacrifie pour l'humanité
est ce que vous vous aimez je crois que
oui et non non non et je pense qu'on
peut aimer les autres que si on sème
soi-même et que quand on est cruel avec
les autres on est fatalement cruel avec
soi même je crois qu'on est le couteau
et l'appeler sa gelée toujours penser
l'avenir question est ce que vous seriez
prêtre comme ça maintenant à pousser un
cri
oui a lancé un crédit
[Musique]
est ce que tu crois qu'il faut coucher
pour réussir est ce que tu penses que tu
apporte quelque chose à la littérature
pas répondre je caire
est ce que si tu trompes et le père de
son enfant tu lui dirai qu est ce que tu
es prête à tout faire si tu aimes sans
tabou voilà
tout tout tout est ce que par exemple je
partais déjà fait l'amour à plusieurs
n'aura plus de sexe tout faire c'est
bien au sec ce qu'elle est et allusion
qu'est ce que tu crois en dieu
non c'est pas dur c'est d'y croire
il m'a déçu alors on va faire une courte
interview oui non quand tu vas me
répondent par oui ou par non
est-ce que tu répondes site était
surprise avec une fille tu vas quand tu
vas au hammam non tu aurais pas rentrer
votre réponse
est ce que tu es prête à tout faire si
tu aimes oui est-ce que tu serais prête
à faire un film porno si c'était un
grand réalisateur bien sûr partiel mais
si peu je serais d'accord oui non truc
très porno mais signé d'un grand nom
j'aime pas ta question s'est passé parce
que signé d'un grand nom s'enfonce ici
un merde mais si c'est un chouette film
porno comme par exemple empire des sens
je signe d'accord donc c'est oui mais
oui mais posé comme je lui ai dit
d'accord sûr et on va s'arrêter à cause
du csa qui passait à des questions plus
soft qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils te fais
rougis au jour d'aujourd'hui qui
pourrait te faire rougir
moi je vais oser y en a mais toi
qu'est-ce qui te faudrait oser quelque
chose de bon ben je sais pas moi
turgis des fois encore à oui je pique
des phares tout le temps aventure dans
la ruche ou alors on va commencer par
toi puis après on fera ses contrats oui
ou non c'est tout ce que tu répondes ça
va très très vite
non si tu te trompes et rapidement c est
ce que tu lui dirai non
qui traite du tout pour le grand amour
tout le théâtre la michodière la
michodière peut-être pas mais oui oui
est-ce que tu thème
non
c'est oui ou non mais celui qui
s'approche le plus de la vérité c'est le
nom dakhla est ce que tu es déjà fait
l'amour à plusieurs à plusieurs femmes
plusieurs femmes par exemple en même
temps j'imagine oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non non plus battus sèchement rejeté
en est ce que tu as déjà utilisé des
supplices questionnaire est ce que tu as
déjà utiliser des ustensiles
oui on n'est pas forcément triste même
quand on est 2e à toi alors tu as dit
que tu n'aimais pas le mot le mot
sensuelle parce que ça te faisait penser
à les traces de rouge à lèvres
sur un mégot de cigarette tue a dit ça
oui tu n'aimes pas faire l'amour tu as
dit aussi vas tu as pas le mot faire
l'amour au japon de la wii tu préfères
le mot tu as dit que tu préférais le mot
baiser outre et son truc
db non est-ce que tu aurais aimé comme
tu l'as dit déjà mais c'est vrai ce que
tu aurais aimé avoir un truc de garçons
ac oui oui c'est à dire quand même que
les garçons le problème c'est que quand
ils ont envie ça se voit tout de suite
c'est un peu embêtant mais malgré tout
aimerait avoir un truc de garçons bon
est ce que tu aurais honte si tu étais
surprise avec une jeune fille dans un
lit en train de mettre des trucs non
est ce que tu peux tout faire si tu
aimes le garçon avec qui tu es mais ça
dépend ce que tu appelles tout moi je
bah oui alors oui oui la vaisselle
c'est ce à quoi je pensais est ce que tu
as déjà été victime de harcèlement
sexuel de la part des producteurs de
metteur en scène oui non un peu oui à un
peu oui
un peu oui moi par contre je pourrais en
dire long sur elle mais enfin mauvaise
j'ai harcelé veux pas savoir
on va arrêter le oui non je voudrais
inviter ça lui plaisait alors pour
savoir pour faire un peu le point comme
ça pour tout les ennemis inter on va te
faire une interview oui non c'est très
simple tu vas répondre uniquement par
oui ou par non
si tu fais l'amour ailleurs que dans un
lit on peut pas répondre par une parle
enfin si ça t'arrive tu dis oui ça m'est
arrivé
oui oui ou oui oui c'était arrivé
ou oui est ce que tu vis des revues
pornos non non je ne sais jamais je la
regarde tu connais pas vertige
est-ce que tu regardes justement
décaissé de tournon non bon marché c'est
la question regard est ce que tu es déjà
fait l'amour à plusieurs jamais bon non
non non
l époque baba et toulalan n'a pas
dépassé les pétards mais enfin tu veux
pas et jamais te tape avec une
communauté un moment toi si mais j'étais
le seul comme une mama s'apprêtait pas
du tout c'était pas bien alors je
n'étais pas candidat non c'est déjà les
dans un peep show non mais qu'est ce que
tu fait de tes journées jobs a déjà eu
des expériences homosexuelles non ah non
alors j'ai pas envie un besoin et il est
bien il est comme non non j'ai pas bien
on en a eu des menteurs valeur lui
[Applaudissements]
l'expérience sanomat zoo n'ont plus
jamais je suis désolé tant pis generix
ont continué à mentir mais on resterait
au fijm en panne environnement j'adore
les animaux
pasqua la limite diensten six adultes
arriver ça tu rencontres une pp vous
vous plaisez font immédiatement
qui peut me répéter ce que tu as dit
tomlin stand sexe ah oui c'était arrivé
ça oui ou non
on peut par contre comment est-ce que tu
aurais honte si un jour tu as pépé comme
ça elle rentre chez toi à l'improviste
chez vous et elle te surprend avec un
garçon alors j'aurais honte d'être dans
ledit avec le mec c'est sûr ce n'est pas
parce qu'elle rentre est-ce que tu
ferais la mort et que marguerite duras
oui non non vaut mille francs dix mille
francs que misère cent mille francs 2,1
millions non un milliard faut voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que tu es assez discret à ces
réserves est assez timide parce que tu
pour épouser un hurlement ouais mais si
je pourrais faire
est-ce que tu je pouvais est-ce que tu
piquerait dans les bagnoles alors jamais
j'ai quasiment jamais vu de ma vie
ouais mais aussi un épi créneau et ben
non plus non plus grands noms il fait
partie plutôt de ceux qui se font piquer
leur très bon est ce que tu es prête
pour faire une petite interview oui non
[ __ ] c'est fastoche tu réponds que par
oui ou par m'en fais gaffe c'est dur est
ce que si tu trompes et ans jules tu lui
dirai non
[Musique]
est-ce que tu qui traite ou pour le
grand amour mais tous oui même tous ses
films magnifiques qu'il fait sans arrêt
c'est vrai ça mais si je t'ai pas
d'accord d'accord d'accord
qu'est-ce que tu thème des sosies toi ce
soit ce soir savary ce soir ça va tu
thème là ce soir ça va ça va nous aussi
on tellement ce qui t'arrive de regarder
les cassettes pornos ouais j'avais fait
ça il faudrait une fois avec un jules
non on était en coupe que des filles des
ronettes way veux-tu tout faire si tu
aimes
oui mais oui bah ouais ouais ouais si un
grand réalisateur te proposer un film
sans porc note accepterait non tu
jouerais pas dans un film pendant pour 1
milliard 10 milliards 100 milliards
mille milliards mille milliards de
milliards 6 oxygène à
est ce que quand j'étais petit mes
parents se sont occupés de ton éducation
c'est non et sans jamais montrer deux
cas c'est d'éducation sexuelle tout cela
on va faire une interview oui non oui ou
par non voilà faut éviter bien vous nous
non oui et non est ce que si tu me
tromper dutronc jacques tu lui dirai non
c'est le c est ce que tu qui très tôt
pour le grand amour la maison tout manar
thomas il est grand oui est-ce que tu
préfère avoir des rapports sexuels dans
le noir dans la pénombre ou en pleine
lumière que décide la pénombre dans la
pénombre
mais oui bien sûr est ce que tu aimes
faire l'amour ailleurs que dans un lit
pas trop vous n'ont pas trop fidèlement
dans ses bottes
est ce que tu lis des revues pornos non
ah bon ça jamais lu playgirl paraît
grave non
ouais tu regardes des cassettes pornos
ça m'est arrivé à settat plus ça dépend
ça dépend des acteurs ah bon parce que
tu fais
est ce que tu peux tout faire si tu
aimes les choses les trucs les plus
terribles tu veux dire ça tu préfères
les plus simples sexuellement c'est là
où tu veux en venir c'est non non ben
voilà c'est clair on le sait est ce que
tu es déjà allé dans un peep show non
continuer je ne sais pas ce que tu as
déjà utilisé les instruments
tu veux dire ce que ouais non je
m'oblige pas à dire ils censurent n'ont
jamais fâché peut-être mais je n'ai pas
souvenir récent de choses déjà eu des
expériences homosexuelles
oui avec dove a déjà eu des expériences
sado maso
oui à tes lecteurs dienstag sexe des
rencontres un garçon immédiatement
partent ensemble faire l'amour jeunes
comme ça a brûlé pour ça ne m'est pas
encore arrivé c'était pas encore nanti
voix brisée reviennent ça pourrait
arriver à notre époque c'est un peu
délicat difficile mais on croit que je
suis à cheveux est assez rapide mais bon
ton monte dans la seconde pour quelques
jours quant au rayon de sites étaient
surprises jeu par un soir jacques pas
rentrer à la maison et lula port eelv
avantage charme il te vois qu'une fille
tu aurais honte
il lui serait absolument enchanté
justement j'en fais je refuse de lui
accorder
est ce que si c'était un travesti très
encore plus grande
ça alors franchement ça ça ne dit pas
grand chose à bord chaos parce que c'est
vraiment ça le côté alors c'est pas
tenté non mais c'est à dire que c'est à
la fois c'est malsain et et grotesque
moyens que j'aurais même envie de rire
donc ça gâche tout alors je vais
répondre par oui ou par non d'accord non
alors si tu le trompe et je lui dirai
non
est-ce que tu qui traite ou pour le
grand amour
oui est-ce que tu tu aimes pas du tout
est ce que tu fais l'amour avec charly
oleg tantine d'ilham l'amour
avec charly oleg pour un million de
nouveaux francs alors un million ouvrant
d'abord un faux calcul en briques
fabriquer 26 ans péter regin
non il ya une audition sinéquanone qui
fait que je ne ferais jamais l'amour
avec charlie malgré toute l'affection
que lui portent ses qu'il est marié que
je connais bien sa femme que je
l'apprécié infiniment et pour moi il est
hors de question de
d'avoir une relation quelconque avec un
homme qui est déjà avec quelqu'un
d'autre part la mairie les a mariés
quand même que c'est que cette histoire
ah non j'aime pas du tout je donne
beaucoup mais je demande beaucoup aussi
parce que je suis assez clair très clair
oui merci jeu que le message passe bien
notés ces messages en yvelines
allez je te veux dire ah ouais est ce
que tu crois qu'on vit moins vite quand
on habite en hauteur alors je n'ai
jamais réfléchi à cette question je
n'étais pas au courant de sujets je
crois que ça n'a rien à voir en 83 tu
t'es marié avec edith d'habitude écrire
sérieusement rangé des voitures font
bien de dire qu'elle ça dépend qu'est ce
qu'on appelle rangé des voitures
je vais quand même vérifier si tu perds
mais je tiens une interview oui non
justement savoir oui tu réponds que par
oui ou par non d'accord on dit si tu la
trompe et je lui dirai oui est-ce que tu
qui traite tous pour le grand amour
je les sers un nom ouais non mais est ce
que tu as des rapports sexuels dans le
noir la lumière ou la pénombre
oui ou non
alors oui aux trois oui c'est très bien
et ça oui et zut il fait l'amour
ailleurs que dans un lit environnement
en ce moment oui là maintenant là tout
de suite pathogènes de dix ans après we
ou encore boa temps tu m'as dit oui ou
non d'accord c'est bien vu ce que tu dis
toujours des revues porno comme avant
non parce que j'ai pas lu de revues pour
nous j'ai c'est pas un truc qui m'a
donné faim même ce que vous regardez
toujours des cassettes pornos et qui dit
non vivres après il faut l'abonné est ce
que tu peux tout faire si tu aimes
oui ouais déjà fait l'amour à plusieurs
je veux dire et des oiseaux mais depuis
quand non non non avant et dit ouais
j'ai vu par tous donc mais une meute de
chiens shipley s'excuser d'être doté
berger allemand bavière une meute de
clébard m'a dit frais est ce que tu as
déjà eu des expériences homosexuelles
non
non alors tu simulait tout à l'heure si
tu étais surpris avec un garçon par ta
femme qui rentreraient deux soirs comme
ça un peu plus tôt que d'habitude on dit
je veux dire si je si je deviens
homosexuels un jour ce qui paraît-il
peut arriver n'importe quand je crois
qu'il faut voir le problème clairement
et puis quoi [ __ ] oui ou non non moi pas
fait des toits pas être [ __ ] non avoir
beaucoup d'amis es homo mais pas toi
n'ont pas pu grand grand pote quoi est
ce que tu as déjà eu des expériences
diensten sexe certu rencontre une fille
vive ou bong comme ça non mais où la
seconde
ouais ouais ouais disent bon il ya
longtemps royal aura dix secondes ça les
sapeurs ont cette seconde non la demi
heure avec des parents toi non non tu es
vraiment une thune pour nourrir sa
famille mais vraiment pu me tue ouais
est-ce que tu ferais la mort avec
marguerite duras ah non ça ne paye pas
ils préfèrent ils préfèrent laisser
crever ses mômes
non je vais charger des cageots
enregistrait jeu mais alors là s'est
déchargée dans un cage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'as pas besoin d'argent là ça va e
il serait bien que devant de mon album
un peu ouais t'as une maison à toi oui
jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yoo move
j'avais touché deux mots entendus
yoo move de dieu et de jalousie pendant
le jingle il faut pas non ça les
mannequins ses limites
bon ballon en cuir un cerf gens leur
faire on allume sa muse de route nous
d'autres mouvements au loto l'ajax
d'amsterdam bouge pas in the game the
game room il se doit
je fais pas
[Musique]
haguenau ici au pays ok sur you just
vous répondez seulement par oui ou non
est ce que ça vous gêne de gagner autant
d'argent non est-ce que vous en donnez à
vos parents oui est-ce que vous en
donner aux gens qu'ils mendient dans la
rue oui est ce que le luxe vous a rendu
plus capricieuse
est ce que si demain vous rencontriez
dans un avion dans un new d'un homme
dont vous êtes folle est-ce que vous
quitteriez tout pour le grand amour
non non ce que j'ai déjà
mais un autre nom un autre mais
éventuellement éventuellement 20 types
habillés en noir la côte est est ce que
vous avez déjà fouiller dans les poches
de christian jamais si un jour ça peut
arriver
est ce que si vous le trompiez vous lui
diriez elle lui dira pas déjà
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est moi
parce qu'on en parle beaucoup de pièces
j'ai déjà est ce que vous avez réalisé
tous vos fantasmes
non non non pas possible si christian un
jour il rentre à la maison à madrid et
vous trouve lit avec une autre fille
est-ce que vous aurez est ce que vous
auriez honte
vous pensez à la scène là oui moi aussi
tout le monde pense à la scène sa mort
yahvé blanc il ya des blancs sur dix
jours vous auriez rente qui vous
trouvent lit avec une autre fille oui un
peu oui
si un jour vous découvrez que christian
karembeu est homosexuel est ce que vous
restez avec lui quand même oui
ah oui bon c'est vrai amour bien l'air
les dernières questions
quand vous aimez quelqu'un quand vous
aimez vraiment quelqu'un est ce que vous
pouvez tout faire avec cette personne et
à la même pas attendu la fin de la
réponse bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous trompiez votre femme vous lui
diriez un ca 7 jours elle a pris ça
cette joie là à
sinon oui c'est pas mal c'est oui ou non
donc je recommence si vous trompiez
votre femme jean françois kahn est ce
que vous lui diriez non je suis semblant
de réfléchir
le mensonge est il indispensable en
amour oui vous trouvez-vous intelligent
oui j'en ai répondu non ça des lois mais
j'y restais les noms vous penserez que
c'est de la danse la fausse modestie
absolument quelqu'un qui vous aiment
va-t-il plus compliqué que ça mais
quelqu'un qui ne vous aiment pas et qui
vous le fait savoir ça vous vexe n'ont
donné vous toujours à ceux qui font la
manche dans la rue à paris j'étais pas
quelquefois a toujours non mais souvent
non non non mais c'est ridicule et la
marine ont séparé du quercy fait qu'on
croit que c'est jamal et oui non est ce
que dans le oui non et vous avez vu
qu'il ya des modulations non non non il
a raison oui il ya l'art dramatique
est-ce que vous jouissez votre pouvoir
non y at il encore un fantasme que vous
n'avez pas réalisé
oui beaucoup chouchou suisse a décidé la
même bien est ce que vous vous acceptez
physiquement non psychiquement
je sais pas là mais non mais non parce
qu'il faut répondre honnêtement si je
suis pas capable en référé pour
maintenance du fait de la fois par an
alors oui il à la ruine
y'a pas blanc et pablo n'en croyez vous
qu'il y a quelque chose après la mort
non avez vous plus de qualités que de
défauts quitteriez vous tous pour le
grand amour
non est-ce que revient vite tourner pour
un million de noms c'est pas assez pour
deux millions c'est pas ça est-ce que
vous aurez un film porno pour 10
millions
là je réserve ma réponse je réserve ma
réponse et vous un million non 2
millions 10 millions 100 millions 100
milliards de milliards
l'argent ne me servirait à rien jugnot
la question tombe sur vous ça n'est pas
les qui s'ils fument se repenser des
maires de noms mais l'historien à 10
millions pour moi quand même à mon âge
c'est une chance de faire les fous 100
millions bras 100 millions via dakar
salessy choisi une version zen par
colère et cette demoiselle peut-être
aussi s'asseoir dans un pays on n'est
pas connu
non non non non non c'est en france
marcel à combien on fait tout le monde a
un prix mais bon ce commerce
il vaut 152 millions déjà bien si le pdg
152 millions ça va encore mais à combien
fed à combien vous allez forcément
imprimer votre prévoit jean n'est pas là
je veux pas aujourd'hui je ne dis pas
voilà j'avais votre âge
[Rires]
jean-françois qu'à louis nom est ce que
vous vous aimez bon disons oui alors oui
parce que ce en quoi je serais fou quand
même
ouais est-ce que vous m'aimez oui
en à bouchemaine
[Musique]
l'affiché des portables qui sonnent
pendant votre spectacle
si vous vous retrouvez en paillers alors
justement jane par oui ou par non
mais sans fautes de français seriez vous
prête à donner votre vie pour une cause
humanitaire sûr si demain on vous dit il
ya plus de famine dans le delta du gange
est ce que vous seriez prête à donner
votre vie oui quel jour est ce que vous
croyez que tous les hommes sont égaux
oui est-ce que vous donnez toujours à
ceux qui font la quête dans la rue non
croyez vous qu'il ya quelque chose après
la mort non est ce que dans sa vie on
peut connaître plusieurs fois le grand
amour
oui si vous trompiez votre jules
actuelle est ce que vous lui diriez non
est ce que vous seriez prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour
oui existe-t-il un fantasme que vous
n'avez pas encore réalisé ouais
newsletters est-ce que vous accepteriez
de tourner dans un film porno non pour
trois millions de francs non mais on
débarque
s'améliore envoie tout entier jean et
j'aime pas mais vous vous y mettez nous
pour la téléphonie
quel ménage mais j'aime pas ta phu même
pour 5 millions 10 millions pour
l'actionner port et le monde mais je
veux bien mourir pour les questionner
mais je veux pas montrer la foule pour
la tchétchénie
ça sonne pas bien ça comme option
humanitaire est ce que vous vous aimez
non
est-ce que vous m'aimez non plus à
l'espace un truc la voûte à dire se soit
particulièrement spontanée quoi ça se
trouve c'est un film qui est débranché
ça
ça nous donne plus
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais été aussi inquiet de ma vie
ça vient de la faune info sa cote est
une réflexion
qui se refait pas
la gauche révolutionnaire d'alfie
révolutionner avec bd julie on a fait
mai 68 ans d'accord j'avais trois ans et
alors et alors dans mes bras
jean-philippe si vous trompiez votre
femme vous lui diriez nadine médite lui
n'a dit ça vous amène à vous ai jamais
fait mais c'est pas à lui demander s'il
écarte les verts mais non c'est ridicule
quand vous allez je vous explique quand
vous allez quand vous à vous et à votre
femme vous êtes comme un petit garçon
qui veut se faire pardonner par sa maman
donc ça c'est un peu ridicule et la
femme et ne vous pardonnera jamais pas
vrai la ville absolument
voilà oui d'autant plus qu'on n'a rien à
avouer c'est mon pote bien donc vous
vous le verriez vous devez absolument
voir quelqu'un qui vous aiment pas qui
vous le fait savoir ça vous vexe non y
at il encore un fantasme que vous n'avez
pas réalisé
joker
quoique que jordan aller sur table voilà
bon est-ce que vous quitteriez tout pour
le grand amour
je dis non non parce que je les ai déjà
trouvé donc que ça y est c'est fait à
ces faits c'est vrai que c'est pour
toujours maintenant ah oui je crois j'ai
mis du temps le ya plus de cinq ans
il ya 12 ans la et la passion physique
continue à l'est elle elle est plus
forte
non pas vos bravo moi j'ai ma
conseillère maintenant soudée
moi je ne fais plus un vin sans
téléphone c'est beaucoup mieux qu'à
douze ans d'arrêt est ce que vous feriez
un film porno pour un million de francs
dont 2 millions dont 3 millions 4
millions du tout 10 millions non et
gagne bien sa vie un film porno pour un
million deux millions
mais elle a refusé kubrick alors parce
qu'elle était à poil un mois pour un
[Rires]
frédéric je pose pas de question et mis
d'accord non toi non pas les 2,4
millions en 5 millions mais non non mais
s'il faut tâtonner 1 milliards de
milliards de milliards je préfère je
préfère l'histoire de propositions
indécentes avec robert redford
oui oui ce film il est nul parce que
mercator ce film est ridicule cette
opérette soit 0 feront tout le monde
l'aurait fait est ce que vous vous aimez
passer mais on leur dit oui ou non non
est ce que vous nous aimez
oui oui
saint-honoré d'inga en bouche on ne
bouge pas pendant lottinghen on ne bouge
pas pendant les kings bien oui non si
vous trompiez votre femme votre petite
amie vous lui diriez nom et vous
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un qui vous aiment pas et qui
vous le fait savoir ça vous vexe oui
est-ce que vous donner systématiquement
de l'argent aux gens qui font la manche
dans la rue non y at il encore un
fantasme que vous n'avez pas réalisé
et vous non non vous remarquez que je ne
pose pas de question à sol parce que sa
femme ait toujours la loose on n'a pas
le même coup droit tu les as vous croyez
qu'il ya quelque chose après la mort oui
est-ce que vous quitteriez tout pour le
grand amour
non est ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs non 2 millions
non 3 millions venant 10 millions non 1
milliards de milliards de milliards non
dits vie pour un million et demi pour un
million de dollars
est ce que vous vous aimez oui est-ce
que vous avez menti depuis le début de
cette interview dans les roues
en rouge
avoir une égale
vous avez bougé dans la bande à serge on
peut rallumer ch désolé ok on allume
heures
désolé on va faire une interview
oui non en les bouches finale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien amanda lear si vous trompiez votre
jules est ce que vous lui diriez non est
ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui est-ce que vous donnez dans la rue à
ceux qui font la manche
oui parce qu'il ya des trucs que vous
refusez de fer au lit oui quoi je me
suis piégé moi même surtout piégée oh là
là j'aimerais savoir il ya des trucs
dégoûtant brawn on a mûri mais c'est
vrai c'est ce qu'on dit à chaque fois on
s'embrasse sur la bouche et que la
langue des trucs comme ça au kram
il ya des trucs et un monde plein gens
aiment faire et moi par particulière
pourquoi un exemple la vaisselle c'est
très coûteux a des poils plein les dents
avez vous réalisez vos rêves d'enfants
n'ont quand même pas fait le plus gros
concours par exemple la république ça tu
aspire à devenir enfin quand je dis tu
es sûr que tu voudrais être pour être
président un jour non amanda est ce que
vous avez déjà eu des expériences
dienstag sexe vous rencontrez quelqu'un
vous rencontrez quelqu'un brighi une
demi-heure après c'est dans les chiottes
du restaurant pour une dernière d'accord
bas
marie thé un raptus dans l'ascenseur ça
vous est arrivé déjà la métare
aimeriez-vous devenir amanda lear la
maîtresse d'un chef d'état oui avis aux
amateurs imagine le pouvoir que tu as
c'est toi qui dirige parce qu'il fait
tout ce que tu lui un mandat avez vous
déjà connu la dépendance sexuelle
oui non mais c'est quelque chose de
terrible
rogge ce week en dit ce mec gelé dans la
peau a à d qui me touche ça pose à sa
bouche et tous et c'est dramatique je
vous écrivais souffre terriblement
est ce que vous croyez à mende à dire
qu'il ya quelque chose après la mort oui
décomposer vous avez déjà fait l'amour à
5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup c'est un gage en
faire des soustractions attend à 5d
masina taille du lit à quatre noms à
trois temps aa oui ah oui oui 4 oui oui
oui oui oui il y avait des femmes non
des animaux
amanda lear allez-vous plus de qualités
que de défauts non oui y at il un
fantasme que vous n'avez pas réalisé
oui ma fille en même temps en même temps
c'est vrai il faut il faut de toute
façon qui est toujours un fantasme non
réalisés parce que maintenant quand on a
réalisé tous ses fantasmes d'abord on a
plus que des bons souvenirs c'est plus
des fantasmes et puis la vie est triste
c'est toujours espérer encore de faire
quelque chose
amanda lear est ce que vous vous aimez
n'ont pas encore tag à venir ça va venir
je travaille là dessus et m'ont pcistes
c'est pas jérémy verbe c'est même moi
sur elle a dit qu'ils reconnaissent à
ses enfants
est ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs non
2 millions non non je lui aurais posé la
question il ya 15 ans j'aurais dit oui
parce que je trouve que j'étais encore
photographia alors maintenant ça
vieillit joly à partir d'un certain âge
je trouve quand même des zones
totalement faux selon le front commun
mettant en gage
là les 100 millions devrait pas payer
arrête
non j'ai pas de la rubanerie alors
alors sexe et oui non à ça va être très
dur pour vous jack lang très dur serez
vous candidat à la candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2007
oui non joker ça commence à penser vous
avoir les qualités jack lang pour
diriger un pays comme la france deuxième
choqué non non bâti à la batterie c'est
très grave de grippe a n'a pas de joker
1g pas me porter une appréciation est ce
que vous êtes en train de faire c'est
très grave parce que ça c'est ça fait
penser à d'autres hommes politiques
bien d'accord mais la question ne se
pose qui disent joker à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème on les gère deux
jeux s'est ainsi rappelé le rôle de
joker wind seulement 2003 oui en 2007 la
question se poserait tempérament
pensez-vous jack lang que vous feriez
mieux que les autres
c'est possible donc c'est oui
pensez-vous être crédible au niveau
international un peu qu'accepte ses
atouts et djerba où ça veut dire oui bah
oui c'est une litote oxymoron les taxis
mauron l'état celestial rhétorique ce
soir et que non g mais on n'est pas chez
cauet là c'est sûr alors jack
si vous étiez président est ce que vous
seriez pour l'arrêt augmentation de
l'impôt sur le revenu je serais pour une
égalité fiscale qui passe inévitablement
par l'impôt sur le revenu donc vous
remets trier l'impôt où ils étaient
avant tout pour refaire toute la copie
fabriqués dans nature raffarin donc oui
augmentation de la csg pour boucher le
trou de la sécu oui non ce sera fait
avant que l'eau choix soit hier les
candidats à la présidence de la
république
est-ce que vous baissez le gouvernement
s'y est ce que vous seriez les crédits
pour le ministère de l'intérieur
oui non ce n'est pas une question
essentielle pourquoi baisser les crédits
il s'agit de les murs et partir donc il
est belle sera pas pour la défense vous
baisserez les crédits il ferait au chaud
dans la défense ne pas s'enfermer dans
le nucléaire et choisira système de
défense opérationnelle aujourd'hui qui
permettra à la france d'être présente
sur les terrains d'opération dakar
nucléaire ne sert pas à grand chose
par contre ne voit pas dans
l'intelligent
et dont l'intervention efficace et à des
onze phrase non c'est pas ça c'est que
de toute façon pour la défense j'ai
compris que jack ne baissera pas les
crédits mais qui veut mieux répartir
l'argent que lui affecté à autre chose
acheter un truc dépasser acheter d
accueil par exemple je serai avec
hauteur c'est ce sont des pensées de
l'argent qu'on jette à la poubelle
etes-vous pour ou contre la
régularisation des sans papiers
oui oui c'est une bonne réponse à
tapotage tapota la dépénalisation du
cannabis
oui non je suis pour une loi sur les
drogues pas seulement le cannabis
l'alcool le tranxène limeray je suis
pour que surtout au delà d'une loi que
l'on ait le courage d'organiser une
vraie campagne sur la santé publique
très bien informer les jeunes des
dangers qu'ils courent et pas seulement
avec le cannabis mais avec l'alcool et
d'autres drogues infiniment plus
dangereux la télé réalité tout ce à quoi
donc on peut en parler
est ce que vous êtes pour la
légalisation de l'euthanasie
oui parce que je ne comprend pas que la
france sur ce sujet comme sur beaucoup
d'autres se cachent les choses et et
refuse de de légiférer et d'autres pays
je pense à la hollande imaginer des
systèmes dans lesquels il y a des
verrous des précautions des ddd
commission de médecins qui épaulent la
famille et qui décide
d'accord donc l'euthanasie c'est oui
l'indépendance de la corse
oui ou non non etes-vous pour ou contre
la dissolution du front national non
l'euthanasie pour le trouvais pas rendre
le front national victime arrive qu'on
voulait c'est le prix fort de mon bac
autrement par d'autres moyens bien
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ce que
la gay pride devienne un jour férié
elle est déjà quasiment arrêt de trois
quarts
[Musique]
vous êtes heureuse en ce moment est ce
que vous êtes une bonne mère chez objet
de dire oui
ah oui est ce que vous êtes prêtes à
arrêter votre carrière si vos enfants
vous le demander non on va revenir sur
la question précédente
pourquoi mais je pense que je pense pas
que c est une bonne marque faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent vous trouvez pas qu'on me
voit un peu trop souvent nu au cinéma
oui vous avez déjà eu recours à la
chirurgie esthétique
ça vous fait peur d'avoir 40 ans bientôt
de dire pris de la drogue oui est ce que
vous pensez être une bonne comédienne
oui est-ce que vous avez déjà chopé la
grosse tête
excusez-nous je pense que c'est ce que
j'ai dit ça va déraper a dérapé
je vous ai tourné déjà des films
uniquement pour le pognon
est-ce que vous avez marre qu'on vous
parle de refaire tout le temps non vous
êtes déjà eu envie de mourir oui croyez
en dieu
non vous donner aux gens qui font la
manche dans la rue oui il ya encore un
fantasme sexuel que vous n'avez pas
réalisé
oui je crois que quelque chose après la
mort à des compositions aux tiers oui je
sais pas je parle dans h et panneaux
est ce que vous vous aimez oui est-ce
que vous m'aimez oui non dit la vérité
c'est vrai en plus alors bien maintenant
anovo quoi bah oui c'est nouveau on
s'entend bien voilà c'est comme ça
est-ce que vous pouvez donner votre vie
pour une grande cause donc les gens du
coin où l'appel génitales par exemple
est-ce que vous avez des tabous à part
le silence
est-ce que vous et vous auriez un flic
m'a gardé est ce que vous méritez ce qui
vous arrive
oui est ce que vous aimez être reconnu
dans la rue est ce que vous croyez la
justice divine
est ce que vous croyez la justice des
hommes
excusez réaliser vos rêves d'enfants oui
est-ce que vous pensez que vos parents
sont fiers de vous oui est-ce que vous
pensez que vos enfants sont fiers de vos
wii est-ce que vous avez menti depuis le
début de cette interview
tout le temps non non j'ai pas mon petit
n'en faudrait pas que ça dérape de
l'autre côté normal
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus